Wait, Quentin Tarantino almost made a "Star
Trek" movie?
And it was going to be R rated?
Like "'Pulp Fiction' in space"?
Yes.
Keep watching for the details about what could
have been.
If Quentin Tarantino doesn't strike you as
the kind of director Paramount would have
had on its shortlist for "Star Trek," you'd
be right.
The humble beginnings of Tarantino's never-made
sci-fi blockbuster came from Tarantino himself,
not the studio.
Tarantino is an admitted fan of the franchise
who has cited the original series' "The City
On The Edge of Forever" and the "Next Generation"
episode "Yesterday's Enterprise" as personal
favorites.
"One more ship will make no difference in
the here and now, but 22 years ago, one ship
could have stopped this war before it started."
It began with a 2015 interview with Chris
Hardwick, in which Tarantino discussed his
love of "Trek" and his potential interest
in helming a movie.
Hardwick initially asked the director about
"Star Wars," but Tarantino pivoted to say:
"I would be more inclined to do a 'Star Trek'
kind of thing."
In September 2017, TMZ cornered Tarantino
at an airport and questioned whether he'd
actually direct such a project.
He responded,
"It would be worth having a meeting."
By December of that year, Deadline reported
he was officially on board, and a writer's
room was being assembled to flesh out his
pitch.
Things moved quickly, and just a few short
weeks after the writer's room was put together,
Deadline reported that Mark L. Smith was announced
as the writer of the proposed film.
Smith's previous work, which included the
Leonardo DiCaprio drama "The Revenant," was
a far cry from the likes of previous "Trek"
writers Roberto Orci and Alex Kurtzman, mostly
know for pennig popcorn blockbusters such
as "Transformers" and "Cowboys & Aliens."
In an interview with Bulletproof Screenwriting,
Smith spoke about writing the script with
Tarantino and working with J.J.
Abrams' production company Bad Robot.
He said:
"They just called me.
It was a like a day later, and said, 'Hey,
are you up for it?
Do you want to go?
And if so, Quentin wants to hook up.'
So I said, yeah, sure."
He continued:
" And that was the first day I met Quentin,
in the room and he's reading a scene that
he wrote.
I told him, I was so mad I didn't record it
on my phone.
It would be so valuable.
It was amazing."
Smith gave a few hints about the still-unknown
plot, but mostly talked about his enthusiasm
about the project.
In a 2019 interview with Empire Magazine,
Tarantino himself noted that the script was
done as he weighed his options for his next
project, saying,
"There's a script that exists for it now.
I need to weigh in on it, but I haven't been
able to do that yet."
A year after the project's announcement, the
film's story was still a tightly guarded secret.
Nobody knew who would star.
But the biggest question on everybody's lips
was whether Tarantino himself would direct
or just take producer and story credits.
Paramount must have been hopeful he would
take the helm, but many outlets were skeptical,
mostly because Tarantino wasn't known for
directing properties that he hadn't created.
While he had directed a handful of episodes
for TV series including "ER" and "CSI," his
films were all originals, with the exception
of "Jackie Brown," which was an adaptation
of an Elmore Leonard novel.
Two years into development, Tarantino was
still uncertain whether he'd direct, and the
internet was abuzz with rumors that he might
be stepping away.
Deadline caught up with him and asked him
about the gossip.
He replied,
"I might be steering away from it, but we'll
see.
I haven't completely decided or talked to
anyone involved.
Nothing is official."
In 2020, Deadline reported Tarantino had officially
dropped out, and that if the movie were to
be made, he wouldn't be sitting in the director's
chair.
Tarantino's ninth film as director, "Once
Upon a Time ... in Hollywood," hit theaters
in 2019.
And while that movie made quite a splash,
his "Star Trek" proposal was still a big topic.
Speaking once again to Deadline, the director
revealed that his "Trek" would be a balance
between classic "Star Trek" and his own "Pulp
Fiction."
Tarantino also expressed his grievances with
"Trek" actors who had tried to tamp down the
project.
He said their comments weren't accurate because
they weren't as in-the-know as they claimed.
He named one name specifically, saying:
"I get annoyed at Simon Pegg.
He doesn't know anything about what's going
on, and he keeps making all these comments
as if he knows about stuff.
One of the comments he said, he's like 'Well,
look, it's not going to be 'Pulp Fiction'
in space.'
Yes, it is!
[...] It's, at the very least, unique in that
regard."
"That's an interesting point.
Come on, let's get into character."
One actor who didn't seem to upset Tarantino
with his comments was Karl Urban, who played
Leonard "Bones" McCoy in the three J.J.
Abrams-produced "Star Trek" films.
In a 2018 interview with TrekMovie.com, the
actor said he heard the pitch and confirmed
just how wild it was.
He also confirmed rumors that the film would
carry an R rating, a first for the franchise.
While some were concerned this meant the film
would be filled with cursing and nudity, Urban
noted that it was more about showcasing the
true horrors of space, explaining:
"You shouldn't worry that it is going to be
full of obscenity and stuff.
He wants an R rating to really make those
beats of consequence land.
... It allows some breadth ... gives him some
leeway to do that."
According to Deadline, Tarantino himself had
asked the studio for an R rating, with Paramount
and production partner Bad Robot agreeing
to it.
The director later confirmed it in his 2019
Deadline interview, saying,
"If you've seen my nine movies, you kind of
know my way is an R-rated way and a way that
is without certain restrictions."
Tarantino also said that producer J.J.
Abrams was fully onboard and likened it to
recent R-rated blockbusters, saying,
"'Deadpool' showed that you can rethink these
things, do them in a different way.
So really, even before J.J.
knew what the idea was, his feeling was, if
it wants to be an R rating, fine.
If it wants to be the 'Wild Bunch' in space,
fine."
Without plot details, many wondered if we
might see Chris Pine and Zachary Quinto return,
especially given that the last film in the
series, "Star Trek Beyond," was considered
a disappointment.
Some wondered if there might be an all new
cast.
But Tarantino himself professed his love for
the Abrams cast, and it soon became clear
that if the film were to move forward, that
cast would return.
In the 2017 Deadline interview, Tarantino
said,
"That's why I actually really was so taken
with J.J.
Abrams' first reboot and how fantastic I thought
Chris Pine channeled William Shatner.
... He's playing the William Shatner version
of Kirk, and he's doing a fantastic job at
it.
I mean perfect, frankly.
And [Zachary] Quinto is perfect as Spock."
In July 2018, Quinto spoke to USA Today and
confirmed his involvement alongside the cast
of the previous three films.
"I'm thrilled that we might have the opportunity
to work with him and see what he would do
with us in this universe.
... I've been a fan of his for years, and
I'm really inspired by his originality."
In his interview with Bulletproof Screenwriter,
Mark L. Smith explained how the story of the
movie involved a "cool gangster scene."
A Deadline report also mentioned that it might
be a 1930s gangster story, which immediately
got fans speculating that it could be inspired
by or related to the classic original series
episode "A Piece of the Action."
The 1968 episode of the original "Star Trek"
series saw Kirk, Spock and Bones land on an
alien planet with a culture entirely based
around Prohibition-era Chicago.
The planet had apparently been visited by
another Federation starship in the days before
the Prime Directive, and that ship unwittingly
contaminated the culture by leaving behind
a book titled "Chicago Mobs Of the Twenties."
Though it may not be what many expected, a
"Star Trek" gangster film certainly fit Tarantino's
description of something we'd never seen in
a big sci-fi movie, and there's no doubt it
would have offered him plenty of opportunities
for the kinds of crime stories he does best.
Following the release of "Star Trek Beyond,"
Paramount was unsure of where to take the
franchise.
While audiences and critics seemed to like
the film, it disappointed at the ticket counter,
failing to live up to its predecessors.
Unsure of how to proceed, Paramount was thrilled
to hear of Tarantino's interest.
But the studio also decided not to put all
its eggs in one basket.
Spock actor Zachary Quinto told Deadline,
there were as many as three different scripts
in development before the sequel was officially
given the green light.
"I think there's a couple of scripts, you
know, because there was a script being written
before Quentin Tarantino."
Quinto told ET Canada that a sequel written
by Simon Pegg and Doug Jung was in the works
before Tarantino approached the studio in
2017.
Noah Hawley of "Fargo" and "Legion" was also
reportedly developing a screenplay that nearly
went into production.
Screenwriters J.D.
Payne and Patrick McKay were also working
on a story that was dubbed "Star Trek 4."
The project was said to be directed by S.J.
Clarkson and would have starred Chris Hemsworth,
apparently entirely separate from the version
entering production in 2022 to be directed
by Matt Shakman.
Rod Roddenberry, son of "Star Trek" creator
Gene Roddenberry, was pretty vocal about his
displeasure with Paramount bringing in Tarantino
to helm a new "Trek" film.
Roddenberry serves as an executive producer
on the many new "Star Trek" series, including
"Discovery" and "Strange New Worlds," and
he also acts as a steward for the brand his
father created.
In a 2021 interview with Forbes, he said he's
a fan of Tarantino, insisting that his rejection
of an R-rated Tarantino "Trek" film had to
do with the integrity of the franchise.
He said:
"I struggle with [a Tarantino "Star Trek"
film] because the way I'm pretty myopic with
the way I see 'Star Trek.'
I grew up with fans [...] saying how 'Star
Trek' inspired them and gave them hope for
the future.
It's the optimism and the messaging in there
that make 'Star Trek' what it was."
With that in mind, Roddenberry didn't love
the idea of "Pulp Fiction" in space.
He continued:
"I'll be honest, that doesn't work for me,
but he is a fan, and I think as a fan, he
probably understands to some degree that 'Star
Trek' has to have some of this [hopeful, optimistic]
messaging."
Many "Trek" fans were excited about the prospect
of Tarantino producing something risky and
daring.
One user on Trekmovie.com wrote,
"Tarantino would bring something fresh and
the characters would be vibrant and logical.
They added that the director's involvement
would "reinvigorate the film franchise."
Others weren't as happy about it.
Another user declared that "under no circumstances
should this be allowed to happen."
On Reddit, user DylanVincent seemed to agree
with Rod Roddenberry, saying,
"This is such a bad idea.
The original spirit of 'Star Trek' gets no
respect anymore."
Another Redditor, Conchobair, offered another
viewpoint, saying:
"I really hope this happens.
This would be insane.
I love 'Trek' and Tarantino, and they [...] together
could be amazing."
With the idea reportedly scrapped, it seems
the naysayers got their way.
As the rumor mill swirled about Tarantino's
"Star Trek" project, several major "Star Trek"
alumni expressed interest in reprising their
roles.
In an interview with Reuters, William Shatner
expressed his love for the director and his
passionate longing to return as Captain Kirk.
He said:
"Quentin Tarantino said something in the paper
that somebody said to me, that he loved me.
And Quentin, I love you.
If you're going to do 'Star Trek,' hey, 50
years later, a few pounds heavier, come on,
not a problem.
... I'd like to do it."
George Takei, who played Sulu on the original
series, told Yahoo! Entertainment of his interest,
but also said it would all depend on the script.
And it wasn't just original series stars who
spoke up.
Patrick Stewart, who played Captain Picard
on "Star Trek: The Next Generation" made it
clear that he'd love to return if Tarantino
was involved, telling The Hollywood Reporter,
"One of my dreams is to work with Tarantino.
I admire his work so much, and to be in a
Tarantino film would give me so much satisfaction.
So, if he is going to direct something to
do with 'Star Trek' [...] I would embrace
it."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movie franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.